[Music]
all right people it's finally time for
the Reuben report fan show round number
two our first fan show was shot back in
May of 2016 which basically seems like a
lifetime ago and we are beyond due for
another crack at it
if you miss it entirely we conducted
twenty interviews in one day with Reuben
report fans from all over the world
talking with viewers from the United
States in the United Kingdom to Egypt
and Jordan to Switzerland and Sweden
what mattered more than the diversity of
their geographic location or their color
or their religion was their diversity of
thought we had selected these twenty
fans out of over 1,400 submissions and I
promise you that we read every single
one of them
these fans wrote us incredibly
passionate essays about their life their
work in the countries that they live in
it was virtually impossible to pick the
final twenty and I can honestly say that
I loved every single interview that I
did that day it was an incredibly long
day for us and my brain was beyond fried
after but it was truly one of the most
rewarding and validating experiences of
my life so many people being willing to
stand up and be part of the battle of
ideas is everything I've tried to foster
here with this show to say it was a
humbling experience is beyond an
understatement
actually it was that fan show which
really sparked the idea of us taking the
show fully independent just this week
you may have seen this already we
crossed the hundred million view mark
and I can't think of a better way to
mark this milestone than talking to you
the fans directly this thing is really
taking off and it's you guys who are the
rocket fuel so for our second fan show
Rubin report calm slash fan show we'll
take you to a submission page tell us a
bit about yourself where you're from
your age why you watch the show and
anything else that you think is relevant
please though try to keep your
submissions under 10 sentences we really
loved reading the submissions last time
but we need to make sure that we have
the time to read them all be smart and
succinct and that'll be your best way of
getting through to us if you're one of
the 20 fans selected for an interview
you'll hear from the Rubin Report team
sometime in April if you submitted for
the last fan show but weren't selected
please
again so that we're sure to see your
submission and if you live in a place
where free speech isn't so free please
let us know how we can accommodate and
we'll see what we can do by the way if
you're a twenty five dollar and up
member on patreon you've got a golden
ticket opportunity to be on the show too
of the fan show selections will be
selected directly from this patreon pool
and we've got a separate forum for you
guys to fill out over at patreon.com
slash Reuben report you know so many of
you have told me that what we've done
here for the past two years has helped
create conversation in a time when
sharing ideas is becoming increasingly
rare this is your chance to say what you
think and be seen and heard by people
who feel the same way that you do you're
just one person but the ultimate
minority is the individual and an
individual with a good idea can change
the world go to Reuben report.com slash
fan show or click the link below and
hopefully I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
you